punishment mild severe abusive changes
behavior only at the moment it is
delivered it doesn't change the overall
level or rate of the behavior so if you
have a child who's doing something
horrible and you smack them it'll stop
it for the moment but it won't decrease
the number of times they do the horrible
thing so there's an alternative decide
what behavior you want sometimes called
the positive opposite and praise or
encourage that that makes the negative
behavior drop out you can actually
eliminate a behavior by rewarding or
praising the opposite behavior
punishment won't do it the so for
example your older boy is always picking
on this younger sister you go to this
boy and you grab him by the shoulders
and you say you stop bullying her you
stop doing that or I'm going to hit you
the child stops the moment and then it
still continues for the rest of the day
is the rest of the week and the parent
runs in and says if I've told you once
I've told you a thousand times stop
hitting your sister that's all going to
fail we know that from decades of
research now what to do the boy and the
girl are interacting nicely you run in
there and you say you are plagued so
nicely that is really great and then you
touch them do that once a day three
times a week you'll change the fighting
that goes on between them perhaps the
worst thing is that punishment traps a
parent you hit or you shout at a child
they stop instantaneously that locks it
into your repertoire even though
intellectually no it doesn't work
overall it works on that moment and it
locks it into you as a parent I see
parents who abuse their children all the
time and they invariably know it is not
helping at all but it doesn't stop
you